le mix des deux
des nouvelles images qui viennent tout
juste d'entrer ben voilà il est arrivé
il est derrière le bureau d'à le bureau
ovale à la maison blanche
alors il pose comme vous voyez pour les
photographier à sa série de décrets
droite il son café et par le tibet dans
le sens unique
alors effectivement il fait la
nomenclature des décrets qu'il a signée
réintégration de l'accord de paris pour
l'environnement donc ce qui découle de
sauce et on ne donne pas de permis pour
qu'ils se tournent excellent retour dans
l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé interdiction d'expulser des
réfugiés qui sont arrivés en soit les
américains pas question de séparer les
familles avec moi ils habitent valais
celle ci au jeu bonsoir à vous deux bon
c'est pas soit toute une journée quand
même depuis temps qu'on en parle depuis
temps qu'on en parle ça y est elisabeth
vos premiers commentaires généraux là je
vous laisse aller où vous voulez qu'est
ce que ça vous a inspiré cette cérémonie
il ce passage de pouvoir c'est le retour
à la décence et à la normalité et c'est
important de dire que la normalité
aurait pu être démocrate ou républicaine
c'est pas un parti pris politique c'est
vraiment cette sensation qu'on revient
dans le respect de l'état de droit dans
le respect des mécanismes démocratiques
donc c'est vraiment le terme de décence
on va avoir la chef d'état quel que soit
son positionnement politique qui aura
une décence politique vis-à-vis de ses
adversaires vis-à-vis des politiques
qu'il va mettre en place le retour aussi
une certaine moralité pas d'une morale
mais d'une moralité
ça fait du bien ça fait du bien
un respect envers les faits et la
science michelle wie je n'ai pas parlé
isabelle je le jure gagné deux bons mois
kim avec eux qu'ils me reconnaissent et
est mort s était de normalité acting
normalité parce que voici un président
anormal
quelqu'un qui j'aurais essayé de faire
ce que le président a fait mais pas ça
pour sa part brisant les lois en
essayant de faire en sorte que les
normes qui s'appliquent elles avaient à
ce poste-là soient transgressés tous les
jours et active parce que voici
quelqu'un qui dit bon c'est quoi ton
problème aux etats unis aujourd'hui mais
l'aco vide c'est les changements
climatiques principe deux choses sur
lesquelles monsieur truffle sur les 4
juin qui a tiqué croyait pas pierre cau
vide
je crois qu'il pensait sérieusement que
ça avait été arrêtée pour la kiné cette
histoire là alors il n'y a rien fait là
dessus vous à peu près café world speed
oui mais depuis qui depuis le jour de
l'élection depuis le 3 novembre jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est presque trois mois ça
il n'a rien fait sur la question de la
part des lits et la réalisation est à
toutes fins utiles pour commencer aux
etats-unis essaient de ne
une tâche d'envergure on le voit ici jeu
c'est notre petite échelle combien ça va
être difficile
alors il y a aussi le fait qu'on
retrouve un gouvernement actif qui peut
faire des choses qui veut changer des
choses et qui veut s'attaquer à des
grands problèmes comme comme les
changements climatiques et aussi le fait
de dire bah écoutez il va falloir
combattre et c'est être c'est par contre
un qui va régler ça
mais falloir convaincre un monde dans
lequel là il ya des gens qui sont dans
une sphère d'information qu'une chambre
des coûts qui sont complètement
différents de la réalité
il ya des millions d'habitants que
monsieur bart hayden a perdu comme
toujours pas gagné et qu'il s'est fait
voler l'élection
exact mais les gens florennes qui
attendaient monsieur tron et beaucoup
d'autres ne se ne se reconnaissent pas
dans ce pouvoir là néanmoins alors les
appels à la réunification à la
pacification monsieur bailon dans son
discours il habite aujourd'hui c'est
important bien sûr qui ne convaincra pas
tout le monde mais il doit réduire un
peu l'espace du précipice entre les deux
groupes
oui oui il doit il doit réduire cet
espace là ça va être très difficile en
effet en raison de ce que disait michel
cédé des bulles médiatiques dans lequel
se situe certaines portions de la
population et on a vite fait sans fermer
si on prend ces informations
essentiellement des réseaux sociaux ce
qui est le cas de plus en plus
d'américains de deux condamnés au
silence ceux qui ne pensent pas comme
doc ces bulles joue un rôle important
la radicalisation l'effet de la
radicalisation
depuis le début du premier mandat de
barack obama parce que c'est
l'augmentation est venu là et on sait en
plus que son un président démocrate en
règle générale la radicalisation
s'accroît or elle ne s'était pas passé
sous trump au contraire elle a trouvé
des avenues politique des voies
politiques y compris jusqu'à récemment
dans la chambre des représentants on a
presque parler de cul et nani caucus qui
quand même va assez loin dans le temps
et dans la formalisation de ce que peut
ressembler représenter cette branche
maintenant présente au sein des
institutions donc ce sont des éléments
qui jouent qui vont contre
mais à accroître ses fractures puis le
plus important peut-être c'est ce qu'a
dit l'ancien président c'est nous allons
revenir d'une manière ou d'une autre que
ça soit sous la forme d'un nouveau parti
que ce soit sous la forme de ce qu'il
prévoyait de faire parce qu'il pensait
perdre en 2016 c'est à dire à nouveau
média un nouveau réseau médiatique
digital où là aussi sa voix ne sera se
fera encore entendre - peut-être mais
elle se fera encore en temps j'ai envie
on aura l'occasion pour reviendra sur
les 100 premiers jours sur les défis sur
la vaccination sur ses relations que le
congrès reviendra sur tout ça mesdames
et messieurs mais vous avez vu
rapidement je veux revenir sur la
cérémonie aujourd'hui cette jeune
poétesse extraordinaire gorman c'est la
femme c'est jean bart hayden qu'il a
vraiment poussé dans le programme en 10
ans est extraordinaire on va écouter un
extrait si vous le voulez bien faisons
nous plaisir on écoute on revient
c'était la toute fin de ce poème elle
est âgée de 22 ans vient de los angeles
et le poème puis on va lire ce texte
ça doit déjà être sur les réseaux mais
on va le lire de rôles wick lemm la
colline que nous gravissons michel un
petit mot sur certains jeunes pointe est
écouté c'est la tradition dans les
cérémonies d'inauguration que d'inviter
pour être enfin c'est souvent des vieux
poète savez comment c'est à kennedy qui
avait réédité
robichaud qui était passé 90 à 100 sur
tournant vers la jeunesse et des
aspirations de la jeunesse pense que
c'est ça que le message l'administration
gbagbo ne voulait passer par ça c'est à
dire on doit travailler pour les jeunes
pour que l'avenir soit meilleur et ça
aussi c'est marquer le contraste avec
soin sur wii elisabeth les et ça fait
référence à fait appel aux mythes
fondateurs des états unis la référence à
la colline la colline que l'on grimpe
c'est aussi la colline qui éclaire le
monde ce que les états unis ont toujours
clamé être les symboles sont importants
ce sont des symboles dignité encore une
fois on essaye de représenter le
kaléidoscope américains essaient
vraiment je pense qu'elle cherchait à
faire la cérémonie d'investiture mais ce
que fait aussi beaucoup ce que font
aussi beaucoup les nominations de joba
et d'un il y en a eu plusieurs
de plusieurs premières en quelque sorte
à travers ces nominations donc une plus
grande représentativité qui était
incarnée effectivement par cette
poétesse aujourd'hui bon mais je vous
parle pas de lady gaga qui était je n'ai
jamais vu on avait la chair de poule et
je n'ai péché d orgueil entendu a été
spectaculaire contre 1,10 à vous en avez
entendu beaucoup plus que moi
il avait tout le vieux en très bon bon
c'est un cérémonie bien fils lille
monsieur oui c'était le gouvernement le
comité inaugural de bail donne le
gouvernement est prêt on a vraiment où
tout était effectivement très bien
articuler puis on voit à quel point tu
juste en voyant joe biden tantôt dans le
bureau ovale avec ça c'est sa pile de
décret exécutif
ils sont prêts à gouverner avec la
transition cette cette interminable
transition on a envie de dire oui
c'était logique mais ils n'ont pas eu
facile alors oui je prouve que c'est
emblématique d'un gouvernement qui veut
montrer qu'il sent prêt ils sont prêts à
prendre les enjeux cruciaux de francs on
va on va prendre ces enjeux-là au cours
des prochains jours un par un mais là je
voulais sur lady gaga
merci à vous deux on se reparle très
bientôt